and it's great to be back in my home
state as I was telling the group at
lunch I'm from Southern California so
don't hold that against me but the bay
area is still has a special place in my
heart
and I think is maybe a little bit better
than LA but don't tell me when I told
you that but as I was mentioned in the
introduction I will be talking about
telehealth and kind of coming from a
perspective of someone that studies
organizations and particularly I've been
increasingly interested in the
intersection between technology and
policy so my talk today overlaps in that
regard
with the talk on Monday about looking at
policies and organizations but
specifically I'm looking at the example
of telehealth so my talk today
healthcare beyond the doctor's office
examining misalignments between
telehealth smartphone apps and US
healthcare policies so again to give a
little bit of background to my research
program that I broadly look at how
technology and communication and
co-evolve in ways that help people
create and share knowledge so as I will
talk about today in the healthcare
context but I've also looked at this
with the change of a policy and
technology implementation at a
healthcare manufacturer and have also
looked at this the role of enterprise
social media and the global offshoring
of digital tasks but to frame my talk
today when we're looking at the
healthcare industry that it's no
surprise that right now that we're in a
bit of a healthcare crisis that we know
that there's high healthcare costs
there's increase in chronic illnesses
and we have an increasing aging
population and coupled that with a
projected physician shortage that we
realize that we really are at the crux
of a crisis one of the ways many of the
ways that have been to address this
healthcare crisis is using telehealth
telemedicine and virtual health all
under the same umbrella and being able
to address some of these issues with the
healthcare crisis particularly with as
we deal with the projected physician
shortage as well so when I talk about
telehealth I want to back up a little
bit in giving a little bit of history of
telehealth
that at lunch we were talking about some
of our favorite papers or maybe books
that we read this year and one of the
interesting books that I read was
looking at the history of telehealth
that it's been around and the notions of
it have been around longer than what we
may have thought about just with the
introduction of smartphones so here
there's a picture of this machine called
the atella ductal machine that was
supposedly a way for the clinician to
feel the patient at a distance so not
necessarily just changing the site of
care from the clinicians office to the
patient's home but being able to also
feel at a distance as well and we see in
the second picture picture the radio
doctor maybe of the patient in bed
connecting and communicating with their
physician remotely and having this
device that is giving the output of what
the physician is seeing how the patient
should be interacting so these
large-scale visions of what we thought
telemedicine or telehealth could be were
even even predated for before our use of
smartphones and and screen technologies
but we kind of see a different notion of
these today where they're mostly through
connecting with a clinician through a
screen whether on an iPad or smartphone
but being able to get back here at a
distance maybe not being able to feel at
a distance but still being able to
communicate across geographic boundaries
now telehealth has been there's
different modalities of telehealth and
mostly for my talk today I'm going to
focus on mobile health or in health but
I want to give a little bit of a lay of
the land before I dig into the details
so for one there's live video which
allows for synchronous communication
this can be clinician to combination as
we see in the the upper picture where a
specialist might be consulted in through
video conferencing we see this a lot
with telestroke services where at the
point of a patient experiencing a stroke
if a specialist is not
available at say a smaller Community
Hospital they can try to connect with
that specialist remotely and there's
also instances of having a live video
and synchronous through these telehealth
kiosks that might be at airports or even
at your local drugstore where you enter
a kiosk and you can interact with that
physician face to feast
synchronously and the advantage of some
of these kiosks that they will have
different devices and peripherals that
you could use such as a something to
measure your heart rates or your having
to take your temperature or taking your
weight but having the access to all of
those tools within the kiosks there
there's also store-and-forward
modalities which allows for asynchronous
communication and this has been an
increase of this has been seen in
dermatology that's very much visually
based and being able to take a picture
of something going on with the skin or
another element and then forwarding that
information to that specialist also with
remote patient monitoring such as in
this case if a patient is discharged
from the hospital giving them the tools
that they would need to be able to
monitor their health to try to avoid a
readmission back into the hospital for
more acute issues and then lastly as I
mentioned that I'll be focusing on
mobile health in health specifically
where communication with a clinician is
involved and also including both
synchronous when you can also have live
video as in with the top picture that
you can actually communicate with a
physician in real-time or asynchronous
such as we've seen with the introduction
of apps such as talk space or
alternative which allows for vision
testing Warby Parker has a similar one
where you might not be communicating in
real-time with that therapist or with
that ophthalmologists but sending your
information and waiting for a response
or a prescription so even though that
we've seen the increase in all of these
different technologies that were able to
talk about today there have
these policy concerns with telehealth
use for one one of the major barriers
has been creating the appropriate
reimbursement models that on one side
that there's interests from health care
consumers but making sure that
clinicians who participate are getting
paid for that interaction so
reimbursements models have been one of
the biggest barriers with telehealth
adoption but with recent policy changes
have allowed for more flexibility with
that secondly with providing quality of
care that there's concerns that is the
interaction that someone has on using
telehealth is that going to be the same
as the interaction that they would have
had face-to-face with their physician
and with issues of quality of care there
have been growing concerns with
malpractice liability someone is this
comic kind of alludes to either you have
a virus or my computer does is that then
when the technology goes wrong then who
is to blame is it the clinician is that
the patient or is it looking at the
technology but there's been very few
policies on malpractice liability
because there hasn't really been much of
a precedent set for this quite yet and
then also that largely that the policies
really focus on defining clinical
interactions so what actually
constitutes as a visit is it one message
exchange with your physician or is it
actually having this live interaction
online prescribing also has been a very
big issue in terms of what constitutes a
clinical reaction to get a prescription
credentialing and licensing as well as
how clinicians can practice over state
lines so even though we see how
telehealth can erase some of our
Geographic constraints with technology
it allows us to talk into connect over
distance that these boundaries in terms
of how clinicians can practice within
their own state lines still remains and
so there's been tensions with policies
and telehealth use with that as well so
as was mentioned that I come from a
perspective of understanding and
studying organizations and so I want to
take a little bit of a step back
kind of frame how I think about policy
so I think about policy as being
constituted by both the text artifacts
of policy texts that say what we can and
cannot do and also technology that is
the means by which we enact that policy
so when we're thinking about policies
that in the u.s. healthcare is very
highly regulated but policies are also
highly variable as well and in part
that's because people can have different
interpretations of the very same policy
even if that policy is very well
articulated and we see this in
healthcare today and also as I will talk
later about how we see this taking place
in and telehealth that telehealth texts
are very variable even across different
states and then as we think about the
mode through which those policies are
enacted that technology as a means to
implement policy but technologies are
also flexible as well and that's how we
think about how to how technology is
design does not always equate with
actual use technologies are interpretive
lis flexible and that the meanings that
a designer has for creating that
technology are not necessarily the same
meanings that the user will take from
those technologies as well and so we
have this interesting tension and
trade-off between how we think about
policy text so policy with the lowercase
P and technology and I draw from Martha
Feldman and Brian Pentland in their
discussion on organizational routines
where they talk about organizational
through teen have two aspects that there
is an extensive aspect and what that
routine means in principle and then
there's a performative aspect and what
that routine means in practice so I draw
from that and how I think about policy
with a capital P and that policy is
constituted by policy texts that tell us
what that policy means in the extensive
aspect and then the performative aspect
meaning the technology that allows us to
enact that policy so we have these two
sides of policy uppercase P
with most texts and technology that
should coincide and should have the
symbiotic relationship with one another
but often times there's different
stakeholders designing them and how they
are implemented sometimes do not always
lead to a symbiotic relationship between
the text and the technology so the three
research questions that I will present
today with thinking about this in the
case of telehealth is one how are
telehealth policies articulated to
Howard tell health apps communicated to
healthcare consumers and three getting
at this tension and this relationship
between text and Technology Howard
telehealth policies and apps aligned
with one another if at all so in the the
study that I'll be talking about with
collecting the policy texts we utilize
the Center for connected health policy
that allows for public information about
all of telehealth policies across the US
and as you can imagine that there are
highly high variability in how each
state defines telehealth on every
different level so in how they define
telehealth what technologies constitute
as telehealth how people are how
clinicians are reimbursed for services
so we pulled every single policy text
document from each of the states and
they include current and pending
policies but we only drew from the
current policies for each state that was
for the year of 2017 and for collecting
the the apps so we wanted to see in
terms of how these apps were
communicated and how they aligned with
how the policies frame telehealth we
collected the descriptions of all
telehealth telemedicine apps from
Apple's App Store there was quite a bit
of overlap between the apps that were in
Apple Store as well as Android apps and
I see him specifically
yes I mean with pulley be all of the
apps um there's no specific category for
telehealth or telemedicine on the app
store so we use search terms such as a
health telemedicine tel health visit
doctor on demand to pull the apps and
then also use a snowballing technique to
see which apps were recommended we had
got a total of 81 apps we had to make
sure that we cleaned up from apps that
were copycat apps that we found that was
a little bit of a trend with collecting
all of the apps and specifically apps
that involved in interaction with a
clinician so we did not include apps
such as a Fitbit tracker app or calorie
counting apps or menu apps where you log
your have a food diary since that is
only on the end of the consumer to
implement that information but it's not
sent to a clinician so we wanted to make
sure that we were capturing apps that
involves some type of interaction
between both the healthcare consumer and
the clinician as well I'm sick yes yes
we did
yeah and mental health specifically apps
that involved with talking to a
therapist since there were some apps
that allowed you to track your mood but
did it have a connection to a therapist
just share the same name but don't do
anything or covering the functionality
and pretending to be that brand yeah
thank you for bringing that because the
the latter that were not necessary
copycat apps were apps that were white
labeled that maybe a specific Health
System was using that app as the
platform so we did include those since
the descriptions also would vary but the
copycat apps what we noticed it would
tend to be apps that didn't have any
reviews that I mean many of them were
not ranked but didn't have any ranking
but would use the same screenshots when
you were looking at descriptions but may
not have any text in the description so
we made sure
that within the the three people that
were looking at the apps and looking at
the final list that we were having
similarity encoding those as well but it
was we were really surprised to find how
many copy I don't have the exact number
of how many copycat apps there were but
it kind of raises this question in terms
of people that are downloading these
copycat apps and thinking that they're
going to connect what the clinician
might also be problematic for this
ecosystem so analyzing the data that we
use a grounded Theory approach where we
had four three different stages of
looking at the data from the policies as
well as the descriptions of the
applications that we gathered and using
the grounded theory approach that we did
it necessary begin with hypothesis
hypotheses but we let the themes emerge
through the data so in the first stage
of coding where we looked at the policy
text documents so again but there's
quite a variability across each of the
states of the policy documents so we
were looking for not necessarily seeing
which state agreed with another states
which states were more restrictive than
others but wanted to look for the broad
themes on how that they were defining
telehealth and the interactions of using
telehealth so the three themes that we
found across all of the policies were
how tell telehealth was defined in terms
of people place and Technology and I'll
get a little bit more into that in the
findings as well and secondly when
looking at the telehealth apps that we
were looking for what expectations do
tell health apps communicate to users
and the three themes that emerge from
that was how they communicated about
speed in terms of convenience low cost
and a high quality of care and then
lastly that focusing on how telehealth
apps expectations aligned with
telehealth themes in terms of people
place in technology those earlier themes
that I presented we looked for instances
on how this policy in tech aligned or
misaligned with looking between both the
telehealth apps and
the policy text documents so in going
over the findings that I'll go over
three main findings but as a quick
overview the three sections that I'll
discuss for the latter half of the talk
is one the theme that emerge from how
policy texts overwhelmingly focus on
technology compared to how they focus on
interactions with people and in terms of
how they discuss place and we'll kind of
unpack a little bit how this might be
problematic knowing that how technology
and the development of these new
telehealth apps will outpace how policy
is revised and defined might be
problematic and how these policies
cannot keep up with the pace of these
new how telehealth technologies change
and secondly that I will discuss how
which might not be surprising at all but
how telehealth apps set very high
expectations for what healthcare
consumers can expect from using these
telehealth apps of course we would
expect that in the apt description to
try to get people to download and use
the app that they want to try to be
persuasive and trying to set a high bar
of expectations but this leads me to
discuss with you the third part of the
findings and how we see these
misalignments and these tensions between
how policy techs are afraid and how
telehealth apps are communicated so
first as I mentioned in talking about
how policy texts were skewed in terms of
how they float over lis focus on
technology itself and those three themes
that I mentioned earlier in terms of
people place and technology that across
all of the policy text documents the
overwhelmingly that they talk about
specific instances of technology and how
that technology should be used so in
three hundred and sixteen instances
across all of the policy text documents
that in terms of live video
reimbursement that there was a lot of
heavy weight on talking about how live
video is often the preferred mode of
communication and those are often the
moments of that will actually
reimbursed there was also a focus on
email phone and fax why fax I'm not
quite sure but this also kind of alludes
to the point of trying to keep up with
technologies that quickly might become
outdated in terms of how people
communicate and interact also in terms
of store-and-forward reimbursements in
terms of what constitutes as
store-and-forward and what type of
information can be collected and sent
and to whom and then also cite
transmission fees so these also focus on
in terms of reimbursements and and fees
and the site transmission fee would
focus on what fees a particular site
might have to charge if they were
sending out particular information and
in terms of people in place where people
kind of was a hundred and forty nine
instances and how people were described
across policy texts and and I think I
had the expectation that people might be
given more weight and how these policies
are being framed in terms of how they
talk about online prescribing in terms
of who is able to actually write that
prescription in an online context in
terms of consent and also a discussion
in private payers and with private
payers referred to insurance companies
whereas public players refer to federal
or state governments and in terms of
place in terms of geography there was
instances of talking about cross state
licensing location in terms of what
constitutes the the site of care whether
that is a patient's home or another
clinical setting where they're receiving
care and also remote patient monitoring
in terms of what constitutes as being
remote patient monitoring and what in
how clinicians will oversee that as well
so so as I mentioned so with technology
kind of this instance into being
specific in the types of technology as
well and how they expect those
technologies to operate and how those
technology interaction
will then be reimbursed and paid for was
overwhelmingly the focus for the policy
texts and we'll get into a little bit
later in terms of why this is
interesting in terms of seeing the
policies framed in this way so to give a
little bit of context drawing from an
example of my mocha my current state of
residence Michigan and how they define
telehealth policy from there live video
reimbursement that they state that it
can be considered telemedicine and they
used a term telemedicine that the
healthcare professional must be able to
examine a patient in real-time
interactive audio or video or both
telecommunication system and the patient
must be able to interact with the
off-site healthcare professional at the
time the services are provided so even
though some states had similar
definitions of telemedicine or
telehealth but it's interesting to note
how specific they were so in this
example that we see that there's like
the focus on the technology itself to
provide being able to provide this
synchronous interaction specifically
through audio or video and that the
patient must be able to interact with
the off-site healthcare professional at
a specific time and Michigan is one of
the examples where a synchronous
telehealth apps such as vision apps um
as I mentioned earlier store that have
the store and forward model are not
healthcare consumers they're not allowed
to use those types of apps and being
able to receive a prescription or even
being able to interact on these apps at
all so in another project that I'm
looking at with the use of Vision Care
apps just to mention that briefly it
creates some of these these barriers in
being able to actually do that study
because Vision Care apps that track
where your location is it's difficult to
even be able to even use the app so some
apps might allow you to choose your
location but that brings up this
question in terms of the ethics and
being able to do that
synchronous support that's a good
question so my thoughts with that is
that I think with there's a concern that
asynchronous or synchronous mimics more
of our how a patient provider
interaction would already be
face-to-face in asynchronous that it
becomes this lesser valued interaction
so with the vision and test apps that I
mentioned so Michigan being one of the
states that doesn't allow these tests so
optometrists have lobbied very hard in
saying that this does not equate to the
interaction that I would have with my
patient when they're sitting in the
chair and I'm asking them do you see
better with one or two that's you know I
have the expertise and being able to do
that as opposed to them doing that
through through an app and I think that
there's also concerns and in terms of
what can happen in between that gap when
you're waiting for the message from your
provider or is there opportunities for
things to go wrong so it's seen as that
asynchronous is or synchronous sorry is
the gold standard by some telehealth
policies framing and secondly to kind of
go over how these apps are communicated
as I mentioned that you know this kind
of sounds a little bit like a no-brainer
that of course they want to propose
speed and convenience also mentioning
about low cost and high quality of care
but even with low cost across most of
the apps there was an example of just
one example of app does not give an
exact cost on how much it would be to
actually use the app so reading the
descriptions that people see that it's
low costs and thinking that it's going
to be less than what they normally would
use in the traditional sense and high
quality of care that is communicated
that assurance that the doctors are
board certified and including very
friendly pictures of physicians and
their white coats assuring that you know
you will be able to get the best of the
best but there's no assurance that you
would necessarily be able to receive
your own doc being able to connect with
your own doctor if your health system is
not participating with
some of these apps so to kind of show
you some examples on how some of these
apps are described and while being one
of the leaders in this category that if
you're feeling sick you can have a high
quality affordable medical care right in
the palm of your hands and on demand
that it's the best way to see someone
doctor minutes board-certified
experienced medical providers and that
you have access to someone 24/7 even
next day availability and that you can
bring health care home feel better
faster who would not want to do this
rather than waiting for weeks out to see
your doctor or if you're in Michigan
like me on those wonderful snowy days
and you don't feel like shoveling your
car out that you can have this immediate
access to someone that would be just as
good to someone that I might see at
Michigan medicine another example of
doctor on-demand
another leader in this category that
they reiterate some of these same things
that you can you don't have to deal with
the hassle of their waiting room that
you can see a doctor within minutes it's
going to be just like an in-person visit
so again emphasizing that it's going to
be the same as if you're going to see
someone in person and that they give
examples of the different types of
things that they would treat being able
to see a doctor on demand with their app
mental health being one of them and that
the services are available with and
without insurance so this mentioned in
terms of cost but don't specifically
mention what that cost is and that they
try to present it as being equitable and
open for everyone and that you can see
exactly what your visit will cost but
we're not going to tell you exactly what
it is now and that there are no monthly
fees so the reason that I wanted to you
know presents you know how these apps
are being communicated and then earlier
presenting and how we think about these
policies being framed in terms of people
technology and in place that if we kind
of go back to kind of my earlier framing
and how I think about policy as being
constituted by text and
technology and taking the socio material
approach to how we would define policy
that we had the social component of
people and their interactions and this
material component here focusing mostly
on digital technology but that can also
refer to non digital technology tools as
well and then also thinking about place
as this material element that can change
and can influence how our interactions
are and when we think about defining
telehealth policy that is constituted by
all of these different aspects so with
looking at the misalignment that we
looked across all of these three
categories in terms of people that we
see that what was missing from also the
apps and that was not necessarily
aligned with the policies is talking
about what is the role of the patient
and the healthcare consumer that's not
really clearly defined that it's putting
all of the onus on the clinician that
the clinician is going to be the one to
see you the clinician is going to be the
one to go through all the protocols but
in this instance that if someone is
accessing care from their home that
there is an activity that then the
patient has to do is do you have
appropriate the or is your device up to
speed do you have Wi-Fi access what
should you do in terms of if you are to
lose connectivity how should you think
about communicating what how you were
feeling when the doctor does not is not
able to feel at a distance so when
they're not able to actually see you
face-to-face that you are losing some of
those moments in that interaction that
we would expect in a traditional
healthcare setting but moving this now
to being in technology mediated that
there's a shift in what that consumer is
going to have to do and that that
expectation is not really clearly
aligned from what the telehealth
tella telehealth apps present and it's
also unclear how to manage the burden on
caregivers and clinicians so the
policies that focus mostly on how
clinicians are reimbursed how they
should perform those interactions but
from telehealth apps that it may be a
way in
being able to broaden access and people
being able to access physicians but
there's no clear articulation in both
the policies and telehealth apps and how
it is going to maybe increase the burden
on clinicians that if you're having to
see multiple people back-to-back with
using these telehealth apps is that
giving you less time that you might be
able to interact with your patient I
mean also with caregivers as well that
if you're helping someone to actually
use the app to access care what does
that mean in terms of what the caregiver
should be responsible for doing so in
the framing of some of the descriptions
that they will talk about how you can
use it for your family but not really
being clear in terms of what your role
as a caregiver should be in terms of
place that's how the descriptions in the
apps note what constitutes as home it's
still very ambiguous and as I mentioned
again with the Vision Care apps that if
you're home it might be somewhere aside
from when you're visiting that my home
right now is in Michigan but if I were
to use one of the Vision Care apps here
in California that I technically would
be able to get through and use that
Warby Parker prescription check app if I
were to pay out of pocket so this Way's
in trying to think about how people
might be able to work around the system
because again if we think about how
technologies are also flexible they
might be encouraging might be offering
ways of having to have these workarounds
working around the policies that might
prevent them to using them in other
contexts and what's also unclear is how
the apps to find the place for
clinicians so in terms of policies that
they make it clear in terms of where the
originating site of where the clinician
might have to deliver care maybe but
from the app there's no clear
description in terms of where your
doctor is is your doctor I'm going to be
at their office when they have access to
their other colleagues to ask questions
if needed or are they at home to being
able to connect with you remotely for
some of the policies are also unclear
about this
with in terms of some of the mental
health apps but for some of the non
mental health apps they're more clear in
terms of where the clinician needs to be
in terms of technology where I would
argue that we see some of the the
biggest misalignment is as with the
focus on how policies are framing them
being very technology centric in terms
of the technology should have this
aspect allowing this type of
communication that if were specifically
talking about email phone and fax which
are in some ways outdated modalities of
telehealth right now that we understand
that technology changes very frequently
and current apps on the App Store are
being introduced and they're also
changing very frequently as well and
that if policies are going to be very
technology centric in terms of how
they're defining telehealth that it's
difficult to think about how those
policies might not be able to actually
capture technology mediated interactions
in a clinical setting
if those technologies are constantly
changing and there's also the assumption
that technology mediated clinical
interactions require no change in
behaviors so I mentioned this earlier
before in the the people the social
aspect but as a healthcare consumer or a
patient what should I then be
responsible for for managing this
interaction and that's not clearly
articulated in the in how these apps are
described and also in how these policies
define what the the patient should be
responsible for beyond payment and the
focus in the policies in talking about
quality of care as being very important
in how these descriptions of the apps
also have a high bar and how we will
promise you low cost and speed and
convenience and so on but there's no
discussion in what should the quality of
the technology what should the quality
of that technology be that if we're
thinking about using this as the means
through which to deliver care should we
think about actually think on how we
define what
is a high bar for the quality of these
apps so the question again about these
copycat apps that if these are in the
markets kind of diluting in terms of
what telehealth can actually do do these
copycat apps and apps that maybe don't
have the best functionalities lower the
quality of telehealth delivery and one
of the concerns of why I'm interested in
looking at this relationship between
policy and technology and telehealth is
that I think that this has a lot of
implications for the future of
telehealth and how we think about how
telehealth can or maybe hinder to the
delivery of care so as we think about
how telehealth is changing the notion of
the site of care that we have to think
beyond just the technology itself but
giving more focus to what constitutes as
place that if we're thinking about
implementing telehealth in home schools
and also community centers how do we
think about how technology can support
other non clinical settings for
supporting people's health and
well-being and also how patient
clinician interactions are fundamentally
changed as we're thinking about changing
the site of care and as we're thinking
about delivering care through a
technology mediated interaction that
there's a shift as I mentioned earlier
and what patients should be expected to
be able to do and manage the
interactions where the burden is not
necessarily only on the clinician in
this interaction and this also brings up
questions in what constitutes care that
is good enough that some of the
proponents of that are creating
telehealth apps would argue that there's
no difference between in-person
interaction for receiving care versus
technology mediated interaction but
others on the other hand as I mentioned
with the example of the vision apps and
optometrists would argue yes there is
quite a difference that I'm able to pick
up things that the patient is not going
to detect that doing a vision tests for
or just renewing your contacts or your
eyeglass prescription is one thing but
someone that has maybe never seen an
optometrist if that that of Thomas has
the expertise in being able to see what
that patient seed pun intended seeing
what that patient might not be able to
catch on their own through using these
applications but some would argue that
if this is the instance where someone
that would not have received care
otherwise is this maybe good enough and
should we think about leaving some
flexibility with some of these policies
to allow some of these telehealth apps
that might not necessarily meet the gold
standard of face-to-face care but it's a
way by which someone might be introduced
and having an open opportunity to get
into the healthcare setting that
normally would may have not otherwise
and and coupled with that too I think
that it also brings questions into who
benefits from using these telehealth
apps the parallel with this that I would
see with a lot of online education with
Coursera and similar platforms such as
that there have been findings that have
shown that those who benefit the most
from taking these online courses are
those who already have degrees and that
are looking to gain new skills or to
further their their education so it it's
kind of helping those who are already at
the top end being able to be able to
access more and being able to benefit
the most whereas earlier
conceptualizations and are we going to
be able to have those benefit who may
not have had X access otherwise or
cannot pay for higher education would
they be the ones to benefit but we see
research that's suggesting that might
not be the case so I wonder in terms of
how some of these policies are framed
and also in terms of how these
telehealth apps are described if they're
catering to those that already have the
technology skills and also the
understanding on how to manage their own
health that it's just an added bonus and
that they're able to get that additional
doctor's appointment or being able to
get a second opinion
but we might not necessarily see those
who
could benefit the most such as older
adults who might have difficulty in
getting access to care through
transportation or relying on caregivers
to transport them might not be that
wants to benefit due to low tech
literacy or low tech skills and also
those that live in remote areas that
might not necessarily have the adequate
internet access to be able to access
these telehealth apps and then lastly I
alluded to this a little bit earlier
that our concern with physician burnout
that's even though that there's been a
crisis in terms of not having enough
physicians and also nurse practitioners
being able to meet the demand of health
care needs but are we introducing a
technology that is going to further
strain the burnout that physicians might
be experiencing already but just through
another medium of interaction I'm so on
that note I will wrap up and I also want
to thank my collaborator for this and
also some of the students that were
helpful in collecting the policy data as
well so thank you and I look forward to
your feedback and questions in
technologies various other technology
like advances and that there's this very
process that straight so you kind of
mentioned that were conscious like
they're lying to people in ste policy so
I don't know
research that looking at the
relationship between a policy yeah so
great question so by collaborator and I
are looking at now what are the specific
differences across the states and from
early findings what I could suggest from
that it definitely seems that there are
some states that might be more
Evelynn c-reactive it may be more
progressive California being one of them
that has one of the most progressive
telehealth policies in other states
where it looks very slow to adopt that
are still making references to fax yeah
as I mentioned and other policies that
might be specific towards mentioning
that there are these applications and
being a little bit more mindful at how
these applications might look across
different clinical areas so I I would
say that it still seems as though these
telehealth policies are still somewhat
slow to evolve that the technologies
really do outpace how these policies are
developed in when they're actually
enacted so we in that next iteration
that I mentioned will start looking at
the pending policies where we can kind
of see some of that in terms of like
what is the degree and how much of a
leap from what is currently on the books
versus the pending policies that might
be actually put into law later on but
overall I would say it's a longer slower
process and the policies are trying to
keep up see there's an early on and I
agree that designer intention does not
equal user practice and I wonder if by
focusing on what the apps were
advertising is their functionality we
might be missing out on what people are
actually using them before so you know
as an example maybe yes this this app
can do lots of things ultimately what
people really end up using it for is
just like messaging saying like hey I
need to read
for this thing I wonder do you have any
of that qualitative evidence in any
direction
how would you anticipate usage is
actually comparing to what the apps are
trying to advertise us they're as
they're guess everyone's yes I'm a great
nice segue to the the vision app study
that I that I mentioned I didn't present
today to try to look at that exact
question as well that are people looking
at using this for I'm not comfortable
going to an optometrist or I've never
been or that I'm just looking at it in
the in-between routine that is just
saving me from having to make that trip
to the optometrist that's an more
defined case in terms of like looking at
Vision Care specifically but I think
that definitely requires like future
work that we're interested in doing and
looking at then how are people actually
using it because in the hands of the
users that's where we're seeing some of
this interpretive flexibility that I can
use this as a way for maybe
working around ways that I want to get
prescription for something that I not
necessarily going to get prescribed from
my apartment care physician that I've
seen face to face or that I'm looking at
this to kind of help with the lag in
between for when I feel a flu or strep
throat going on so looking at ways also
and how these workarounds because I
think looking at how people are using
some of these apps for what they might
not interpret as these workarounds but
it might be workarounds like to the
policies so I definitely agree that with
our next steps and actually looking at
how users are actually using this to
perform and they're the ones that are
not necessary knowledgable about
policies per se that this app is being
offered I can use it and not knowing
that oh the reason that the state of
Michigan has this law that I can't do a
vision up here but if I go across state
lines somewhere else that I can use it
and not necessarily understanding that
you're then not being compliant with the
policy but because that policy isn't
embedded in the tool that you don't see
the policy text in the same way
yeah the current insurance market is
based on procedure there's some like
push towards like outcome based payments
do you think on that like this the type
of the misalignments that you see and
the trends of the use of technology
might play like a bigger role because
now you have to guarantee that the
patient actually gets better as opposed
just I saw you and I get paid
yeah that's a great example so in the
case of these apps I would argue that
they're not necessarily always aligned
with that continuum of care if someone's
being recommended when they leave from
surgery or seeing their doctor the app
that maybe their health system provides
that I'm going to need you to check in
or I'm going to try to see you in two
weeks but I'll have a video consult when
it's connected to the continuum of care
that I would argue that it could that it
is aligned with the changes in the model
for going to more value base rather than
fee based care but some of these apps
where you can sign up download it use it
and your primary care physician may not
even know that you're that you're using
it still kind of adds to this the
discontinuity is that can happen with
being able to see a doctor that might
not be integrated in your care team so I
think in terms of how these apps are
being collectively part of someone's
care and monitoring process that I think
that it can support that endeavor for
pushing for a value-based care but these
one-off apps that someone can still use
I think can either further hamper that
and try to have that on continuum with
care you think should be a facilitator
between like this tension between
collisions and technologists and you
invented earlier that you know
technologists might be getting the upper
hand in terms of lobbying and things
but should there be a third party or
should it be one of the two or like how
do you see that moving forward yeah from
our conversations earlier where that who
gets to say and how what the policies
are like who has the the lobbying power
to say that we don't think these apps
should be on the market can definitely
differ but then who's also being able to
construct that design I think that
clinicians definitely should be part of
that design process in creating the
technologies because they're the ones
that can can allude to that well if
we're adding I need to make sure that
I'm not pained you know back to back
within 20 minutes for a request because
I'm the only physician on call for
taking the requests for the doctor on
demand at night that that's really kind
of leading to my own burnout that they
are able to be able to give a context in
terms of like how they experience the
practice of care in ways that
technologists that are developing these
apps might miss that it's great to
understand what the healthcare consumers
would want so that they know how to
market to them but that's where we kind
of see the biggest gap in that
clinicians who are on the other side of
having to make sure that these apps can
stay in existence and function also have
to be part in that conversation as well
with creating the apps in person and
then there's complete sort of ml but
there's also this interstitial space
where you were your primary care
physician will like be made accessible
through an app themselves so it's not
some sort of going on route around the
system it's you know now you can message
your primary care physician or maybe you
know maybe even get a quick conversation
with them or you can use them all sorts
of things with them and wondering where
do those kinds of applications fit into
the ecosystem how do they adjust the
sorts of theories you're building or not
yeah that's a really
shouldn't I think to your earlier points
and being able to interview users so it
would be great to interview users who
have used these telehealth apps that
were being referred to a specific app by
their physician or a nurse practitioner
because then they know to kind of search
for that here's a logo I'm looking for
I'm looking for my health system they're
given the exact link to and and and I
would also be curious to know and how
that affects trust that I'm not kind of
just using an app just because the
description looks convincing or because
I just need something very quickly but
it would be interesting also to see in
terms of like health outcomes that when
someone has someone that is the same
provider that they're being able to
connect to of someone that recommended
them to use it that I would argue that
is being more tightly aligned with the
continuum of care but you would have to
know how to search knowing what you're
going in searching for as opposed to
getting one that's like listed at the
top 10 or the reviews that are that are
most convincing but most people right
now what they would be going through is
searching for unless they've been
recommended to go to it or just kind of
in the wild wild west of looking for
what app seems fit for that time how
many doctors inject what's up either
patients I'll be hearing that I heard I
talked to a couple of doctors say like
this is growing very rapidly very and
now patients just what's after doctors
not even I specialize that just
traditional yeah I have the the figures
on that but in terms of the telehealth
policy restrictions like most states
would prohibit that especially if it's
not an app that can ensure privacy and
that the information is being protected
so like the offhand messaging even
through like social media that most
states prohibit that type of interaction
would be interesting to see what the
stats are and what physicians you know
are providing that type of additional
communication and for whom I've seen at
least among my cohort is using a
telehealth app to get a prescription for
birth control and that's like a very
specific ad for a specific focus so just
wondering if you see apps like that as
common like a specific after specific
focus another example I could think of
it's like getting a prescription for
medical marijuana card before it was
legalized yes for both of the examples
that you mentioned the latter I
initially thought when I saw one of
getting the prescription for marijuana I
thought like oh is this a weird copycat
app that we need to you know delete from
the data and realizing that it's like oh
there actually are apps like that and
and I have seen an uptick in some of
these specialized apps especially with
women's care I can't remember the the
name of the exact app that I've was
thinking about but the but I I think
having something that is more
specialized with especially sensitive
topics and issues that people would
ascribe more trust that well if I'm
getting a telehealth app that's specific
for women's health that I I know that
it's going to be someone that has a
deeper expertise in this oh so similar
to with some of the mental health apps
that I know that it's going to be a
therapist that is participating on this
and has expertise and being able to
communicate in this way so I think that
we will see some more of these
specialized apps as people are looking
for specific instances and like what
type of care that they want but to my
earlier point it's this question of how
can we make sure that is still
supporting like the continuum of care
still remains to be seen - okay
[Applause]